Um, do this Buffalo wild wings thing
is just insane, dude. The Buffalo wild wings thing,
pull it up is when they,
the Astros got caught cheating in like what 19 or no,
22,000 some year they won the world series.
And I guess that they just came out that they were cheating or something, right?
Something like that. No, you don't know. Yeah.
Basically very basically if I'm wrong, who gives a? Basically it,
so, so the,
the coach or the com or whatever the was like apologizing kind of, and be like,
cheers, never wins. So we didn't win. So don't worry about it.
Whatever we did was the S deck about it, you know?
And so also you better believe if I was playing baseball,
I would be cheating so hard. Like there's no way I wouldn't be cheating.
I would be betting against us and then not playing as well.
I would be like saying, nah, that's not what happened.
I will be doing that kind of all day long. That's not what happened.
I'd be throwing people under the bus. That's not what he dude.
That's why I'm the catcher, because he did that. I should be right field.
And they'd be like, Oh, you know, this is what the Leah says.
And some other guy would be like, no.
And then I hope I would get the leg up in a cheating fashion. Understand.
Cause it's just baseball and I'd be raking in mils. But
uh,
so Rob Harris tweets breaking Manchester city band,
breaking Manchester city banned from champions league
for two seasons by F and find 30 million
euros, U E F a F F a. And um,
so, so Buffalo, wild wings, right?
That's how you punish a team that cheats.
And I guess people thought, and I wouldn't even have known, but I guess Buffalo,
wild wings change.
It was saying that was insinuating about how the Ash
Astros should be punished.
So Houston took to Twitter and started roasting them.
First of all, Houston, I love you. I legitimately,
you're one of the cities I like going to and performing
in the most. I love Texas dude.
And you know, I wouldn't say this right now. If I wasn't serious. I love Dallas.
I love Austin. I love Houston.
San Antonio is that place.
And I love Texas because Houston
sure it's hot, but it's also banging everyone in.
There is either a hot chick or a tall corn husk. And dude love it.
Dallas,
love how the girls go out with the hair that looks like battlefield earth just
sprayed up. Like it's 1987.
Love the dudes in Dallas that won't not
tuck in their shirts no matter what that
outfit love, Austin. Sure.
It me off that the slogan is keep Austin weird because you're not funky.
You're just a city with a bunch of weirdos in it that,
and every one out of every eight people has a mustache,
including the girls because they think it's interesting,
but they're still banging. Okay. And everyone's there for music,
but Austin Love ya. San Antonio,
you have the Riverwalk and everybody's drunk on it.
Love Texas. Okay. But Houston
and I hate saying this dude,
but we have a problem because dude,
the thing is you became a little bit of a
when Buffalo wild wings change,
it happened to say this thing about Manchester and the air
FFA. All right, because you started saying, well, I'll never eat there again.
Cutting up Houston, Buffalo, wild wings,
cards, by the way, what kind of a fat?
So Aria that yeah.
Have a Buffalo wild wings membership card. Hey guy,
cut that up. Anyway.
Guarantee you were sweaty when doing it
also it's 2020.
Who's eating wings.
Who's still eat wings, dude. You know, the last time I put a wing in my mouth
at a party years ago because I was starving and that's all that there was.
And I got there late dude. You should not be eating wings, man.
That's gross hookers or whatever.
The Hooters that place legitimately thought it was named hookers for a
second. Like, come on, man. What is this place?
Hooters dude. Hey dude, for real, just call it hookers.
Hooters. No,
don't call it hookers because I believe those girls should be making that money
and you should be tipping.
Those girls and those girls are working hard and some of them got a family to
provide for. I like those girls. You're you're you're uh, you're uh,
you're trying to make that money and you're being positive in society,
but company just call your place. Tit,
you know, uh,
anyway, these people in Houston were like, look at this,
look at this. Let's just pull up some of these,
find some of them in woods and we'll just come on.
Dude was my Twitter app where my Twitter at, uh,
go to some of them want to go to got this gift for Christmas. Look at this,
by the way, got this gift for Christmas.
They're cutting up the Buffalo wild wings card. Dude.
You got that gift for Christmas, from a who's someone that hate you.
Hey dude, that's Buffalo wild.
That's a Buffalo wild wings gift card, dude, dude,
sad. Hey guy. That's cool.
Also sad.
Um, look at this guy, Kenny Swift, this cook this cook name by the way.
And you're just lost business in the fourth largest city in the U S and
surrounding areas.
That's how you punish social media accounts that pop off with a DJ Khaled.
Jeff that says, congratulations, you played yourself, Kenny Swift,
with the profile pic of that cat that that lady's yelling at or whatever the it
is, dude, shut up, man. Shut up
by the way, the Houston Astros cheated.
So you're coming in to defense for people that robbed
money in base in baseball,
you butt hurt. Kenny Swift couldn't sound more like a
country singer by the way,
God. That's so
ridiculous that they troll. you. it, dude.
I juiced in your being, uh, the people in Houston that are doing this.
You're being a. You're being a straight up. Dude, you're being a butt hurt,
dude, I would have, I don't eat wings.
I wanted to run to Buffalo,
wild wings and get all the wings and put them in my pockets. And they'd be like,
you want a bag? And I go, no, are you kidding me, dude?
I'm aware in these no bag, that.
They go in my pockets, wings.
And then this happened,
get ready to be. My baby's Buffalo,
wild wings pulls the even more move and they tweet back
a day later.
So last night was the roast of Buffalo, wild wings,
courtesy of the city of Houston.
And honestly we deserved it well done.
H town for coming to your team's defense.
And we're sorry about what we posted.
Hey Buffalo, wild wings.
You just solidified something.
I'll never eat there because you went back on an
opinion that first of all, doesn't matter.
And now it's news.
And now I know about it and I'm not eating there. And guess what?
Buffalo wild wings. And I'm serious about this next time. I see my friend,
Jason, stay them. I'm telling them not to eat there too.
So that's two huge,
equally famous guys that are not going to go to Buffalo, wild wings anymore.
God. How imagine
being sorry about it.
About making fun by the way,
Buffalo wild wings. Why are you even tweeting about this?
The only thing you should be tweeting about is, Hey, we got wings.
That's every tweet that Buffalo wild wings should tweet should be them
saying, Hey, we got wings or reminder colon.
We got wings or Hey, do you like our wings?
Or Hey, you must like our wings.
Why are you tweeting about the Astros at all?
But if you do tweet about the Astros, do it once.
And if you take a stance and pop off in a humorous way,
and then you feel the heat welcome to my world, you.
But don't apologize for it. Especially when you know you're right. See,
this is why I can't do.
I can't trust you now because you did something that you thought you stood
behind. And then cause the mob came running the fat sweaty palmed,
Buffalo, wild wings, eaten gift card.
Having as gift certificate,
they kept coming.
You guys felt the heat and apologize about some that you know is right.
And you know that you still stand behind or you
don't and you change your mind because these fat sows
find them. You know what? I don't trust you.
So how can I trust what you give to me to put inside
my body wings? No,
don't eat wings by the way, dude, unless you want to get cancer.
There's some other than radioactive. Hey dude, they're orange.
Don't eat anything. That's orange except an orange
for real man. That's crazy, dude.
Buffalo. Wild wings.
No mother, Buffalo.
Wild wings.
Buffalo.
Wild wings. That's.
Awesome. When I do it like that.
Buffalo wild wings,
Buffalo wild wings. Hell yeah, dude. That's awesome.
I'm glad I figured that out. This is a silly goose time.